hi guys welcome back to the 70th ever
episode of the iced coffee hour
my name is savannah smiles
and so far the podcast is made you did
not give me that information i don't
know what you were expecting me to do
yeah i'm assuming it's probably made
around 105 000
so thank you guys for tuning in and
thank you for appearing on the podcast
macy yeah of course what else am i going
to do work well i think jack has uh
something to tell you and that's we
wanted to film it
you guys are pregnant
how did you know
no i'm not we're not pregnant uh yeah
jack is pregnant yeah
no
uh i own a house now
congratulations thank you thank you
thank you so i uh will officially be
moving out of this residence uh as soon
as possible congratulations do you have
a move-out date in mind uh well ideally
it would have been tuesday uh but we're
pushing it back a little bit due to some
uh technical difficulties
and uh hopefully maybe monday or
something
so you're not going to be around for the
holidays i thought we were going to have
a big old
family holiday but we're going to be
empty nesting
this christmas i'm sad i don't i don't
want you to leave yeah i know you were
trying to convince me yeah to back out
of the deal like two days before closing
i told jack that he doesn't need his
deposit it's only three percent he
doesn't have to close
it's sad i was telling even me no i i do
feel sad about that it's just like
you're like a staple part of the
household you like are
weird i don't want to say weird but you
know that like awkward teenage son that
just stays in his room what's the
difference i'm sorry okay so let's let's
set this straight what's the difference
between awkward teenage son
and weird well weird
i just think awkward is a little
different because like you i mean i hear
the dating escapades or some of it that
i just think oh
we're starting this off a little
aggressive now aren't we no but just
like you're like our our awkward teenage
son that lives in there like you come
out of your room you got your headphones
on your hood up and you're like
just like yeah that's true i never
thought about that you are a bit like
that just you close your room and you're
just we haven't seen you
you come out just to eat in the kitchen
and then you go right back into the room
all right all right i'll take that as an
endearing thing
great thank you guys thank you very much
anyways i'm moving out i'm excited to
have my own place uh
although i am so excited i am honestly
i'm a little upset that i'm leaving you
guys uh this has been a great time
living with you guys for such a long
time you don't you don't have to leave
though that's the thing rent
yeah why don't you rent out every room
except for one but just stay here and
then if you need one room there just go
there
i'm sorry guys but i think it's time the
uh you guys are empty nesters right
isn't that isn't that a saying yeah
empty nesters i just at least i guess
you're preparing graham and i for this
probably about 25 years before he'd
actually become empty nesters maybe alex
moves in maybe just get alex i'm sorry
alex is already renting a room guys that
is totally off limits uh yes
how about this why don't you show us the
house tell us how many offers you've
made so far leading up until this point
okay so uh i've been pre-qualified for
probably four or five months and i've
probably made
uh seven
seven offers six or probably five to
eight offers so quite a few offers uh
i've learned a lot thank you graeme
you've helped me out a lot through this
process
and uh it's crazy out there it is like
uh it's like warfare
honestly in the in the housing market or
buyer and why didn't the other offers
get accepted
uh well i made a few mistakes a few
novice mistakes in the beginning uh
that's one reason why they didn't get
accepted explain these novice mistakes
for people that don't know i i feel bad
because i feel like you're roasting jack
a little bit right now because i could
see with i've heard about a lot of these
mistakes i would have probably made them
too jack to be fair like some of these
things i listen to i'm like no that
wasn't smart but i probably would have
accidentally done the same thing too
well of course you would have i think
anyone would have if they didn't know
what they were doing so so jack calls
the seller the seller directly he wants
to offer 560 for the property
and
in the span of a minute jack goes up
from 560 to like 5.95
and the seller doesn't even take the
offer he then shops it around
and then gets back to jack saying would
you go even higher and start something
yeah i'll go higher chops that around
i'm telling y'all
so basically the seller had no intention
of closing for a week out into the
future and i got the highest offer on
the house with still a week left to for
the seller to make their decision and
they basically just went around to other
people
i entrusted the seller big mistake uh
and basically they just went to the
people saying hey this guy offered this
much can you beat that uh yeah yeah no i
could
i would have probably done the same
thing on the first one but i don't think
the second time they would have called i
would have offered anything higher but i
can see definitely on that first one i
think it's understandable especially
when you're like really excited about
getting a place and stuff
not all of us worked in real estate
graham oh okay yeah you're you're a guru
you're really not good but a real estate
genius okay not all of us are thanks
anyways another house i lost out on uh
it was initially listed at like 460
460 i think and it's funny because four
or five months ago when i first started
looking i was looking in that price
range like 460 450. um and graham said i
should try to go under 400.
unfortunately well i don't know if this
is unfortunately but the house i i
bought was listed at 600 000.
so i mean
obviously it is a little bit of a nicer
house but not 140 dollars nicer than the
initial house 460 that i put an offer on
uh it just goes to show the how uh
insane the market you wrote it off for
460 but that didn't get accepted so
what's the fourth season well actually
i'm sorry it was itself it was listed at
440. it's sold at 465. okay and here's
another issue that i ran into if you
guys are trying to buy a home um i
offered so actually the property was
listed at noon i saw it at one and i
submitted an offer uh i think at asking
uh at 5 00 p.m
and that night they got i want to say 10
offers uh it was between like 8 and 12
offers
uh all over asking
so i was pretty much screwed fortunately
uh i came back with extremely aggressive
offer and then they counter offered
uh to like a few people that were still
in the running
and uh counter correct
what multiple counter offers are they
multiple yeah yeah yeah exactly so and
and i accepted their counteroffer
thinking okay i'm gonna get the i'm
gonna get the property uh oddly enough
their counteroffer was something called
the best and final which i was not aware
of and it wasn't really disclosed to me
by by my agent unfortunately and i lost
out on the property because all i did
was accept their counteroffer this is
the one that i reamed on jack after this
one uh not this is half your fault half
the other one uh you know what it's 80
20. it's it's 80 their fault but yeah a
best and final you never accept because
everyone pays more than that right right
the only reason why i would know not to
do that is because when you were getting
the la place you were trying to avoid
that and you explained how the whole
multiple counter offer thing in the best
of first you're like i'm trying to write
this now if it was just a normal counter
offer and i would have accepted it we
could have been a contract right but
this was like to multiple different
people and i just accepted their offer
which was probably i i think i offered
460 and then their counter was 462 and i
was like okay 462 sure i'll do it and
then it sold at 465 because someone
offered that so i it was just three
thousand dollars and now that house is
probably worth five hundred and
ten five hundred and twenty 000 honestly
right well let me ask you this question
do you like your current place more than
that place yeah i like i like it more
but i do think this house would have
been a great investment
and
for me right now i'm 22. i don't think
it really matters for me to have a place
like i really love the point
jack
oh my gosh yeah i am 23.
sorry my birthday was like three days
two days ago so i'm just i guess i'm not
used to saying that but yeah
but i mean you're going to want to find
a place so you're going to like for the
next probably three
plus
years i would imagine i wouldn't think
it's gonna be a place that you're gonna
be in for like ten or more but you're
gonna wanna find a place i don't see you
getting a place and then wanting to move
like six months a year later right i
don't like it enough to stay there for a
few years right well we'll get on to
that in a little bit but the the lesson
to learn here is if it's a multiple
counter offer that means you have to go
above the counter offer if you really
want the deal at least in this market
and if it's just a counter offer then
you can accept and you can be in
contract but that should all be
disclosed to you by your agent yeah so
if i were your agent i would tell you
never pay ask price always low ball the
property and that way you don't have to
leave see that's hey that's genius for
that
so never have to move out so anyways uh
that was those were a couple bad
experiences another one was i got i got
the cops called on me uh that was a that
was an issue and very very very
embarrassing tell the story wait is that
the is that going to be the title of
this podcast
cops called yeah that would be funny
that would be funny so so graham gave me
the genius idea of reaching out to the
listing agent and asking if they would
also represent you as your buyer's agent
right and then split the buyer side
commission so i can basically let's say
it's a 600 000 house i get a 6 000
credit in closing costs or something
else
um so i decided to reach out to the
listing agent on a property i really
liked and i said hey i was wondering i'm
a prospective buyer like would you be
willing to show me the property or
something like that maybe my wording was
a little off but i did not specifically
say can you represent me as the buyer's
agent i've always done that but exactly
so that was that was i mean that was my
fault and then he said sure it should be
open between now and like and he gave me
a range of time where the house would be
open for it and i figured maybe they're
doing like an open house you know maybe
i just show up meet the guy and he'd
show me the property
wrong that's not what happened i showed
up to the place what day of the week was
this
because
this was like two three months ago it
was not a sunday night okay yeah but
it's not a saturday or sunday would have
been
thinking that we're still in this market
yeah in this market usually they'll have
windows of showings that they'll be like
i'm there 12 to three to show up during
that time it's pretty so i figured i'd
be safe just showing up he thought i was
actually the listing agent so he left
the the lock box thing on the door
he thought i was the buyer's agent yes
representing my client right so he left
the lock box on the door and there was a
like four numbers on the top of the lock
box and i was like oh these are just the
four numbers you hit to open up the lock
box get the key open up the house so i
kept on trying over and over don't know
what those four numbers were think they
were completely arbitrary uh for some
usually wouldn't he tell you what those
numbers are
ahead of time no because it's on the mls
that's how you know that oh you would
have okay so he didn't tell me what the
numbers are i just kept beeping my way i
was like why isn't this working why is
this where i was showing up i was like
maybe he's inside yeah first we want to
thank attitude for sponsoring this
episode of the iced coffee hour podcast
i absolutely love having a great night
of sleep and there's something about it
that just helps me wake up refreshed and
productive and that is exactly why i
think that bedding can be just like an
investment you get a good pair of sheets
and you get a great night of sleep it's
as simple as that unlike cotton that
consumes a ton of water ettitude sheets
are actually made out of 100 bamboo and
they are so soft that some people even
call it vegan silk did you know it's
like vegan silk alex
well now you do seriously guys because
of attitude i think i have gotten some
of the best sleep in my life and that
has led to me being way more productive
and efficient during my work day same
goes with me jack i actually sleep a
little bit hot at night so because of
how breathable they are i've gotten some
of the best sleep and there's no reason
not to try them you got 30 nights and if
you weren't completely satisfied you can
return them for a full refund but trust
me you will love them and right now you
can actually get 20 off your order plus
free shipping when you visit
attitude.com iced coffee and that's your
promo code iced coffee at checkout
remember that's attitude as an ego
attitude again that's edited.com iced
coffee promo code iced coffee for 20 off
and free shipping thank you so much
attitude for sponsoring this episode and
back to the podcast don't know what i
was on that day but he definitely wasn't
inside dogs started barking kept trying
and then i got a call from the listing
agent uh and he basically said what are
you doing you're scaring the sellers
because they have like a camera and they
were monitoring me
uh and he said you're really freaking
out the sellers and then we had like
five minutes i won't exaggerate it was
probably two minutes we were going back
and forth trying to understand and i
wanted like i didn't understand that he
didn't know that i was
you know a buyer not a buyer's agent
and basically we just went back and
forth a lot of confusion that he said
hey you're going to have to leave the
property um the sellers or the sellers
are requesting you you leave and i was
like and i was like really embarrassed a
little frustrated because i drove all
the way out there
and i thought i made it clear enough
but apparently i didn't and i drove home
and then he called me when i got home
and he said yeah
they were they were calling the cops on
you basically because they thought it
was a break-in
because they dealt with something like
wearing i mean i would just
my normal clothes i wouldn't say it was
anything fancy but
i mean i maybe a hat and like i had a
beard growing out at the time oh maybe
it's the hat yeah maybe the hat daylight
haven't shaved in a few days showing up
too far just frantic just beeping away
at the threat i don't think it matters
who it is if i saw somebody outside of
her house beeping like that and they
were getting multiple failed attempts
and i wasn't expecting anyone to be
coming in at that time i would probably
call the cops no matter what they look
like right so anyways that happened i
was really embarrassed a little
frustrated and i was standing in here he
was on the phone with me saying that
they were going to call the cops on me
and uh
then
i told him i was like will you still
represent me as the buyer side agent and
we can split the commission and this is
what he said oh no we don't do that here
uh i don't split my commission at all
and then i was like uh why and then
and then and then he said that's like
you going to the mechanic and saying i
picked you as this as the mechanic i
want to operate on my vehicle so you
give me a discount and i was like no
that's like going to the mechanic
telling them the issue with your car and
and already knowing what it is and then
asking for i don't know well i feel like
that's going to the mechanic you already
have the part and you're just like i
just need you to do the work for me
exactly or just saying there's a place
doing it cheaper down the street would
you match their price it was basically
we both had poor analogies yes
and then he he basically just well no he
didn't basically say what he did say was
uh all right well you have good luck
with that and then he hung up you should
call him right now tell me you just got
a place
hey man i just got a place way better
than that place
no i i don't wanna start any argument
okay because i also don't even know what
the eight i don't remember okay it was
like three months ago okay all right
well random random realtor out there
jack is beefin
i'm beefin what are the finances like
what sort of loan did you get sure so i
got a conventional loan 30 years uh 2.6
2.874
was my rate which is pretty incredible
you had to do that because i got 2.875
right i had to beat him so uh yeah that
was that was pretty exciting for me
because that's basically like free money
and uh also what else is yeah
it's free real estate it is free real
estate and what's your payment every
month it's gonna cost me about three
thousand dollars a month to keep this
house up and running with all the rooms
rented out because i'll also have
several roommates
so
and i should be able to rent out the
rooms for a pretty good price
how much are you going to rent each room
for um it's going to be 8.75
and i'm also going to tack on a maid fee
uh whatever it is divided by however
many that's fair yeah roommates just
because and they'll also clean their
room and everything so i figure that's
that's good and it's also in a great
location uh i'm gonna be pretty kind
with with amenities and stuff like that
i'm going to maybe provide paper towels
toilet paper stuff like that try to give
a hotel
experience so that's nice you learn from
the best jack that means jack's room is
worth like probably 1200 a month for the
location
oh yeah no i wouldn't yeah because it
also has its own bathroom yeah maybe
some more so who are we moving in oh we
got to find somebody for 1200 a month no
you wouldn't do that 1200. no god no you
stay in the room we have another angry
teenager we're just like just we never
see him know them
no one actually my sister oh you said
well it's 1300 a month
let's see that i just had the 1300 what
did i say twelve hundred and then well
the main fee the money and stuff like
that
the poor i know how much it costs here
yeah but i know but the cleaner fee plus
the pool plus we wouldn't charge
anything extra for utilities oh okay
with utilities that makes sense
with utilities to finish it off the
numbers on the house uh if i were to
rent out two rooms at 875 a piece
alex's room let's just say 10.75 or
something like that uh another person
moving oh also i'm gonna furnish i think
two of the rooms and charge sixty
dollars per month or so to furnish the
rooms uh and then also another room i'm
also gonna rent out so there's four
rooms i could potentially rent out the
numbers on the house so i think it adds
up to where i'd be cash flowing about
700 a month ish and uh i think that
would be about a seven percent cash on
cash return and if you include the
principal pay down the piti the p-i-t-i
uh that means i'd be getting uh i think
about a 15 or 16 return annually which
is crazy because honestly in this market
it seems like doing something like that
would would be so difficult right and
that's not even accounting for potential
appreciation which obviously one should
never count on but yeah i didn't think
it was possible but now i'm doing the
numbers and i was like dang maybe i did
get a decent deal on this house so that
feels really good that's good we gotta
congratulations yeah okay sure so all
i'm just gonna show a couple photos i
don't want to drag the the whole house
thing on for too long
um but here let me let me pull it up so
i'm just gonna show i'm just gonna show
like three photos of the house but this
is the front yard can you can you just
explain what you're seeing right now uh
so i am seeing a
brown house
with a two-car garage out front a
large window above a double door entry
graham what's your opinion on the facade
i like the palm trees uh
not a huge fan of the color
nice landscape though overall i would
say i just don't like the brown
fair enough
yeah i i agree with you it is next okay
then we got the pool
uh picture two yeah i like picture two
nice pool looks very blue yeah doesn't
look like there's any plaster issues
that there's a couple plaster issues but
it's mostly cosmetic all right i like it
yeah i like it too and then picture
through it it's also the pool got a hot
tub
inside
i like that kitchen it's going to be
really great for entertaining cats are
going to love this
you're going to be up there on the
counter all day
uh great refrigerator now you did
negotiate to buy uh
jeremy's refrigerator yeah don't measure
that yet so you bought a refrigerator
not having measured the size you know it
is what it is man okay it is what it is
so anyways the point of this whole house
conversation guys is that if you don't
think you can find the deal in this
market
you can okay you just gotta look for it
for about four or five months if you
rent out all of the bedrooms you too
could have a good deal if you rent out
all the veggies and the garage yes
storage no i'm not renting out the
garage but i would and you could and you
could airbnb via pool have you seen that
you can't airbnb oh yes
yeah there's now an app where you can
rent out people's pools by the hour yep
did you believe it we should try that
for the sta family and see how much
money like we can make i'd be curiou i'd
be curious about that i just want such a
high price but uh
the point is content graham it's not
about making between twenty and eighty
dollars the point is content twenty
eight dollars twenty dollars an hour and
eight dollars oh gosh no no no i i think
realistically you charge like 150 an
hour okay so 50 hours an hour sure might
do that okay the next thing uh this is a
conversation that's going to be very
exciting i was planning on just doing
this
not on camera but since we are doing it
you know a podcast right now i figured
it's a good time
graham i'm thinking about making a video
my own video what sort of video
something about the house okay i think
it'd be really fun
and i like the whole idea of starting up
something not that i'm starting up
anything
but having 100 creative freedom over
something i can make and i think that
like that is extremely appealing to me
and i just wanted to know your opinion
on that
you think so yeah
and and what are you what are your
feelings towards that um i think as long
as it doesn't impact the second channel
or the podcast that's it i frickin told
you what oh you didn't tell me oh he
told you about that yeah you told me
about this a while back he's like how do
you think we even feel i'm like i think
he's gonna be fine as long as it doesn't
affect any of the channels yeah so but
how long have you felt this way because
a while ago we did have a conversation
where you said jack if you were to ever
have your own channel like like you
definitely you clearly were against that
idea that was a time where i was a lot
more busy yeah a lot like back before
alex and living in santa monica yeah i
don't know i think at that time you were
you were probably putting in like eight
to ten hour days
six days a week eight to ten hour days
six days a week bro santa monica less
than that more oh my gosh santa monica i
all i did was work and go surfing like
once every two weeks maybe it was that
we were doing a lot back then but i
think if you had brought it up back then
i'm like where are you gonna find this
because some something else has to fall
back yeah no i agree with you that time
if i if i did do my own thing it
definitely would cut into my work so
that's one of the reasons why i held off
but now it's like i'm realizing like i
definitely think i'm making enough money
doing what i'm doing right here and now
i'd like to to spend a little bit of my
free time doing something maybe as more
of a hobby something i'm more passionate
on so i'm pretty excited about that and
maybe i don't even like it because i've
realized i love like creating content
for other people that's so fun for me
but if i were to start my own channel
maybe i would love it maybe i wouldn't
like it and if i didn't like it i
wouldn't continue doing it so all right
jack and to be fair sorry there's a low
battery thing here guys but to be fair
graham said the same thing to me because
i had a channel before this it wasn't
very active but he said
i mean as long as it doesn't cut into
your work and we all work a lot here so
but he said uh you know go for it so
yeah no i'd be fine with it
just if i see anything fall back the
quality of either the podcast or the
second channel fall then that would be
worth having a discussion about but as
long as the quality is the same and if
anything i think if you enjoy yourself
somewhere else it's going to reflect
everywhere so i agree and i think also
it's like i mean but for anybody i think
that the job usually comes before the
hobby so yeah
but uh
i know you've wanted to expand on the
podcast more yeah so i would expect that
like that sort of growth this would be
something that you would do
after everything else is said and done
oh yeah yeah of course i'm for it it was
nervous i was really nervous to bring
that up to you to be honest with the
channel yeah i was really afraid of us
uh
i don't know because i feel like it's
been like a like a weight over
over my my shoulders or whatever for a
long time now i just feel like i have
the biggest i told you so because you
brought that up too yeah you're like how
would graham feel i'm like
i'm gonna say yes it doesn't affect
anything i don't know i'm afraid of like
what what was the worst case that i was
gonna say i was gonna say no or i'd be
like well then i want 50 no no no i
don't think you would want anything i
just think like you would have felt like
a little
uh
disapproving of it and also
why yeah because you you would think
inevitably somehow it would cut into my
work okay so and also it's like i mean
this job everything i do with you guys
it's one of the most important things to
me in my entire life and i wouldn't want
to do anything and you guys have seen
what i've done like i wouldn't want to
do anything to get in the way of this so
honestly do it do it have fun with it i
think that a house tour is like the the
the best content that you could do
especially is the first video i know
exactly and i it wouldn't even really be
a house tour because i would love to do
that on this defense get someone to live
in the house
uh for free but have them just do some
vlog like one vlog uh
no i would i wanted i would want it to
be a little more hands-on and i wouldn't
want it to be a vlog every time like i
would try out the cooking thing and then
i would try out staying in the cheapest
airbnb i've been seeing that trend that
looks really fun you're going to be
doing what i'm doing with lifestyle
content but with a finance emphasis
where i don't think i would have
necessarily financed emphasis i would
just do whatever i wanted to i'd post a
short i just have fun with it to be
honest that's it you'll make one video
you're gonna make the house tour video
it's gonna do really really really well
and it's gonna give you a bit of a false
start that's right i agree i think on a
new channel
house tour you're picking like the two
best topics right there the past two
things about a channel
um
i'd i've well as we've seen with us to
family 10 uploads
10 uploads that's where you get the
sense of like what's going on so we'll
see
no that's fair
yeah
don't touch him don't acknowledge him
he's going to wait right there here's
who's my handsome kitty he's a handsome
kitty that's all he likes you just call
him handsome and he likes that
ramsey
such a pity such a handsome boy all
right what else do we have ramsay's
going to join us so macy i want to know
your opinion on this what do you think
of graham's starting and only fans
uh like
what type of only fans because i know
only fans has this rep for having a very
adult provocative what they do
provocative uh
content
but there are other people on only fans
like colin sameer right and they give
bts content and i think if it was
something a little bit more like the
colin sameer i think 100 right away i'd
be like yeah i don't even
doesn't even bother me any like explicit
adult content i mean
it's it's your body into your choice on
those things but i
you know i i might be a little
uncomfortable at first but i'll support
you no matter what you want to do how
far could i go on that before it you
would feel uncomfortable okay well first
of
all
i'm laughing i'm just like i'm how do
you know at what point does it start
like making you uncomfortable okay one
thousand percent if you did adult
content and then try to get me on in on
it i would be a thousand percent like
that's fair about solo stuff
um
i mean
it's just like if it was anything where
he was
you know sexualizing himself i might
feel a little uncomfortable but i'd
support you i mean we're we're partners
so what we do but where is the line
drawn
like is it let's say i'm like at the gym
i got my shirt off i got like you know
two weights i'm looking good
uh i think where i would start to get
uncomfortable but again i would support
you would be anything that wouldn't be
allowed on instagram like anything that
instagram would see and take down i
think i would start to be a little
instagram would take it down that's
pretty easy yeah you have to do a lot to
get it taken down not really well i
guess i know where the line is for girls
on that uh which
it would be like really anything beyond
a bikini or anything topless for girls
you're just like you're out
just like double check
you got to keep them there he's the star
of the show now um yeah but i think
that's where my mind would start to
become a little uncomfortable but again
i said i support you and what
you know i support you that's what we do
yeah
yeah
i would feel the same way if you started
and only fans if if if you wouldn't want
your parents to see it then i would be
i mean i'll just be against it that's
the way i that's the way i see it i feel
like i feel super uncomfortable half the
time posting anything on instagram in
general but um also like even just being
in shorts i feel like half the time i'm
like
oh gosh i feel so weird posting in
shorts or like i don't even think on my
public account i have a single picture
of me even
like at a beach in a bikini where you
can tell i'm in a bikini yeah
just cause i i feel uncomfortable with
that
yeah so i don't know for myself i've uh
i tried to get my identity verified
didn't work because they don't have my
id on me now but i want to i don't know
obviously i'm not going to post like
even even shirtless i'm not going to do
that but uh or maybe if you subscribe
whenever i don't know but uh
i don't know i want to do it i want to
see how much money i'd make in a week
but i don't know what i would post you
can make a video on it
maybe
we'll see but it's not going to be like
i don't want to take my shirt off or
anything but i but i could don't say
that dude don't worry maybe maybe i do
maybe you have to maybe i don't it's off
the record
if you want to get something that's
really attractive of you without it
being revealing all you need to do is
take pictures of your arms and your
whole only fantasies your arms because
just do that like holding a coffee or
like something like that i'll just do
that
and do bicep curls like cough oh with
bankroll just holding bankroll coffee
yes all right
we'll see i i'm i'm like 99 i'm gonna
start one
uh because why not but i don't know what
i'm gonna post you're gonna have to
subscribe what you follow subscribe or
what do you think uh
i've heard through the grapevine
subscribers i think it's subscribed
that's what i was thinking too because i
think it was the same as twitch
yeah because why not if colin and samir
are doing it i'm gonna do it too that's
fair yeah
all right guys so graham just pulled up
the initial emails that i sent a couple
years back when i wanted to work for him
he had no idea who i was i was a total
fan at the time extremely embarrassing
i've been not looking forward to this
moment for a while now but i think
graham is going to read them
part of me wants to do this on the
second channel because it's really good
but we're going to do it on the podcast
because we can clip this part out and
all i'm asking guys because we're not
putting in on the second channel just
subscribe if we're if you're at this
point jack did not want to do this video
for a long time two years yeah he said
no to this video macy's not heard these
emails uh alex has not heard these
emails
and uh jack did not want this getting
out extremely embarrassing i was like
desperate i like how you came up with
the topics for this video and you bring
up the emails well no i've been telling
you impressions lately especially that's
me the first email you sent me february
2nd 2019 the title is just
lunch okay nice hey graham my name is
jack selby and i'm a subscriber to your
youtube channel you are truly inspire
you are a truly inspiring person and a
true role model for me i love your
videos and make sure to like them when i
watch that's good
i'm 20 years old and like you when you
were younger i'm not
i'm not entirely sure what i want to do
in life i have huge dreams and
aspirations but i let stuff get in the
way i recently decided to get into the
real estate business because of you
however i'm not sure how well it will go
over i know you are in la i live in a
neighboring city ventura i was wondering
if you i was wondering if i could drive
out to la and buy you lunch so we could
talk it would mean so much to me if i
could just get some advice from you or
we could just talk i am by no means
looking for a job or money from you i
just want to talk my cell is blank or
you can reach me by email please get
back to me thank you so much okay so
first email is great it's just lunch so
a few things one it was probably way too
long
two you didn't offer him free food
i said i would buy you lunch didn't i
did you
take you to lunch
i think it was implied that i would be
yeah yeah yeah yeah buy you lunch so we
could talk yeah
so
i figured that you know looking back i'm
like okay that's not very embarrassing
although i definitely could have done a
better job it's like you don't just
subject something you know you know
what's interesting
was your dad a little bit offended
or is he gonna be offended that graham's
the reason why you got into real estate
when he is an appraiser uh no i mean the
reason why i'm so interested in personal
finance investing is because you know my
dad would tell me about it growing up
but now i'm curious right how many
emails do you see like this a day now
well now i mean i don't check the email
anymore but but alex would have a better
idea how many emails do we get a day all
the time i mean
we get so many and you know if we took
up everybody's lunch offer
um i mean it'd be impossible actually i
got uh
a dm on instagram of somebody who said
they love this to family they're gonna
be here this saturday and they wanted to
take me to super sushi
wow i don't get that many and i was like
wow you might be able to take it yeah
listen you might you just do it
yeah you're lucky it's somebody who
wants to like actually go out to lunch
with you usually it's people are like i
can't get a hold of graham i want to
take him to lunch i'm like
i don't even get to you're expecting me
to pass this along to graham and i'm not
even getting free food out of this i'm
not invited to this lunch what the heck
guys yeah i get those i get this too but
um to answer your question graham we get
probably about
probably at least 40 a week
people who want to take you out to lunch
and that's probably on a slow week yeah
yeah wow all right so then you sent
another email
two days later
great follow-up there okay thanks
uh same email thread hey graeme i sent
you a message two days ago
in one of your videos you said that a
very important thing to do when picking
careers is pick one with the opportunity
to grow you also went on to say how
important becoming an assistant real
estate agent is after watching over 25
of your videos i've decided to become a
real estate agent i look up to you and i
wish uh and i wish that i had
realized
sorry i should it's just it's it's weird
i haven't i haven't
i haven't uh looked through these emails
since
i first like i don't i honestly i don't
think i've ever read these emails to be
honest with you i picked the last one in
the first one so everything in between i
haven't seen it okay
it's it's it's just weird seeing this
back then that's all it's knowing you
now okay
it's derek
what is it man read it man read it
jack no i can't read it
it's either me or jack has to read it
from his mouth
i'm not gonna say any of this from my
mouth it's so embarrassing to come off
different okay here it's not from your
mouth it's from your fingers yes okay uh
that sounded inappropriate
yeah okay
because i i want this because
i don't want this to come off the wrong
way okay you want me to read it yes i do
frick all right
all right um
uh you went you also went on to say how
important becoming an assistant real
estate agent is after watching over 25
of your videos i have decided to become
a real estate agent funny uh to be just
like you
see you're laughing too come on jack
i look up to you so much
and i wish that i had the talent that
you have
please graham i would love to be your
assistant in real estate
that is so desperate please graham i
would love to be your assistant real
estate uh i believe that i would make an
amazing real estate agent i have a
personality that has always gravitated
people towards me
i believe that i have the charm
oh my god did you read that
oh my god this is uh i believe that i
have the charm
and persuasive ability to become one of
the best real estate agent yeah real
estate agents out there that's funny
i would give you 50 commission easily
maybe even 75 percent
that's silly negotiations i know that's
literally just saying i'll give you 75
percent 550 but maybe i would pay no
it's like okay yeah you'd give 75
uh
i will have a horrible standard of
living currently if that means paving
the way
paving the way to future success i will
have a horrible standard of living
that's that's desperate again
uh please consider this graham it would
truly change my life hyphen jack lloyd
selby trying to be very fast wow
my hands are like clammy every single
time you text me because
graham mentioned these emails when you
when you first start dating now it says
jack lloyd selby wow all right but uh
okay so jack this is like
because i
kind of have my lifestyle channel and
then i talk about relationship a lot
stuff a lot this is like you went on a
first date like you're going on a coffee
date and then afterwards you're just
like
i want to marry you and i want to be the
father of your children yeah yeah that's
literally how it was hey grant okay this
is also may 15th so this is about
three three months yeah i just i just
kept sitting on it man yes i was still
hoping you'd reply to me for some reason
yeah after a few months all right and
then may 15th so he had just started
working with you march
may
so this is three months i waited
wow so he
we literally both came into your life
from the same place knowing each other
i thought he was working for you for
like two or three months before we
started i had something i know i had
been working
because i think it was right around here
yeah it was may
i mean i'm not gonna get into it yet but
you'll see
um
okay so hey graham i just wanted to say
that i have so much respect for you i've
been following you for a few months now
and i've recommended you to all of my
friends very true i've recommended him i
even watched his channel with my dad
yeah because one of one of my best
friends was in your your friend group
and uh she's once i started dating
graham yeah and then i found out you
were working with him yeah then she was
like
he literally has told all of us to watch
graham yeah that's cool oh i was i was
obsessed uh badly not that bad
uh i got a chase freedom card because of
you i got a roth ira because of you i've
made a few hundred bucks
i've also been constantly exploring
possible real estate investments
it only took i mean three years now
luckily i have a good credit because i
listened to you you have made me you
have made a massive impact on me please
respond like i said i have
please respond uh
i have tried contacting you before i
would love to buy you dinner or
something or something
wherever you want to go i will drive to
la i live in ventura 50 minute drive i
want to assist you in any way i can
because of the way you have helped me
if you want you can make a video talking
about how your youtube videos have
affected people to increase your
validity and have me on there although
it's not publicity i'm seeking
i just want to meet you i idolize you
i also find you better than all the
other youtube creators in the financial
area take that kevin
here is some background on me
i am 20. my dad is a real estate
appraiser and my mom is a kindergarten
teacher i'm going to go to ucsb to study
economics possibly go to law school
afterwards i wanted to become a real
estate agent but my dad doesn't support
it
[Laughter]
why doesn't he support it
uh
he
well he was a real estate appraiser yeah
and i mean they i'm sure that there's
kind of a a unique relationship between
appraisers and yes so i think he just
doesn't like he didn't want me to go
into anything with sales okay i think
was his idea um
okay i love investing here are some
things i do i have a cit savings builder
account 2.45 interest rate bragging
i invest in several different etfs i
have some mutual funds through vanguard
i have a roth ira and i have the and i
have the credit card previously
mentioned my financial situation is
actually very good for my age so i'm not
looking for handouts period please just
a chat or something let me buy you
dinner you can contact me email or cell
phone
please this would truly mean the world
to me and then so uh the next one is
basically me referencing a jubilee video
that graham appeared on which was
millionaires versus minimum wage worker
right and this is the most i think just
about the most desperate i got uh
i i also followed up later that day also
the same day
also
this is so bad
what breaks my heart
is that i was also going to sign up for
that jubilee video as a minimum wage
worker so i would have met you then that
would have been incredible had you been
on that video with me yeah that would
have been insane that would be really
cool at the time i was working a minimum
wage job and i was so close to signing
up for that video i think i'd felt no i
don't know if i'd filled out the form
that they sent via email but i was going
i was going to sign up for it uh so yeah
i said that broke my heart uh
and then i said on may 19th four days
later hey graham you didn't respond to
my emails maybe you just didn't see them
i could just be an intern for you and
just do whatever you want i would work
for free i
i just want to talk to you
i've been following you on youtube
forever i look up to you please consider
that do you need someone to run errands
for you to sift through comments or
emails to research things for you i'm an
econ major at ucsb i have four months of
summer right now that i can dedicate to
you please man i can even edit your
youtube videos i know that that's a pain
for you i will edit videos for free your
time is worth much more than editing
youtube videos three years ago i said
that i know and it is it's worth more
and then
and then i responded graham said
hey jack sorry i didn't see the last
emails i get so many what's the best
number to reach you i could use some
help with some random things if you want
to give it a shot
i remember uh seeing that email
i like of just thinking about it all day
and i said and i also dm'd him on
instagram a couple of times we don't
need to read those um
and then i said hey of course my
personnel sell or hey of course
exclamation point my personal cell is
cell
thank you so much graham exclamation
point exclamation point exclamation
point my heart skipped a beat when you
emailed me
feel free to call or text me anytime but
it worked and how fast did you respond
back you want to know what worked though
can't see yeah
jack you want to know what works for me
whoa whoa whoa here's what's crazy i
sent jack this email at 2 35 p.m
he had a full response back to me at 237
he wrote all of that and responded to me
in two minutes well it's clear i didn't
think about it too much because i put my
heart skipped a beat and you're not i'm
not trying to make you my girlfriend man
i mean i probably would have at that
time
so some people don't know this i
originally saw graham in a jubilee video
that same one that you referenced and i
thought he was cute and then he
mentioned something that aligned with
one of my
uh my best friend and i had this theory
called the happy hour sushi theory and
it was that if somebody understood the
value of going early to happy hour sushi
they understood the value of money
because they understood like where to
save and
whatever it was this whole thing and
graham specifically referenced that so i
thought he was cute and i followed him
on instagram and then i reached out to
him via
just responding to one of his stories
with like a joke because i figured he
wasn't going to respond
you want to know our first interactions
it was a giant pool it was a story of a
giant pool and with the temperatures
like this is you know it's 110. and i
wrote that's not a pool that's a giant
jacuzzi and then he wrote back ha ha fax
that was the that was our initial
conversation i think it was romantic it
was yeah
i forget when i was way more into it
than i was and i'm his girlfriend yeah
i was yeah i remember sorting through
and just like that was a funny comment
and ah it's funny that was it yeah yeah
yeah yeah we just started talking about
pools and jacuzzis and la houses from
there
it's interesting how people change over
time you know jack i was kind of with
you too i mean uh when i put my video up
i think jack was the first one to
comment on there but graham didn't
comment and he commented on other
people's video and i was like oh that's
because we called you first
you're the only one in the beginning
that we called oh you want to know how
did you bother commenting alex you want
to know how that conversation went yes
i was i was in um i think i was wrapping
up out of a meeting and graham runs into
the bedroom and i'm sitting there and
i'm like
you know i'm in a meeting it wraps up
and he's like holding his phone watching
his videos like
i think we found it and it was like
we found it and then
he did exist oh sorry he was holding the
phone towards him he said i think we
found it i'm like
what because i couldn't see what was on
his phone and he turned around and then
i was like oh oh somebody filled the
assistant position he's like
yeah and then just walks out of the room
i was like
okay
all righty then but you know what's
crazy is how many emails we get jack
that were that are just like yours that
you sent that uh we just don't see
because we get so many of them yeah how
many other jacks are out there
i don't know i've tried to hire a few
people to do some random things uh here
and there uh but unfortunately it's
never worked out to my but what about
one like that what about one of those
emails because we get a lot of those
emails yeah we almost never uh get back
to them because there's so many right
i think i think a lot of people in that
position that are that desperate
would would do something of their own
a lot of people would just start up
their own you know channel and start
taking action like that i think so you
did you think so no i know i didn't but
well that's because i also had no idea
how like i consumed so much youtube but
i didn't even know where to start on
that and i knew for a fact like i could
provide value to you in any way possible
i knew i and and i would do it for
nothing you know so
right before you guys hired me um i was
going in full time on content creation
and i had just gotten my first
sponsorship
and on tick-tock
and um
i passed on it after i got hired but
so i i kind of get what you mean grab
yeah
anyways i'm sure that there are people
out there that would be willing to do
the kind of stuff that that i did and
i'm sure graham
would have done in the same position but
they're it's a little tough to come by
at least in my experience it's timing i
think it's all on timing like i've
gotten a lot of even for myself for my
channel where i've had people offer to
edit but editing a is one of the my
favorite parts of making content i love
getting in there and doing like goofy
little things zoom in
like you could give
i could
we all
all four of us in this room could have
the same exact footage
and we'll come up with completely
different videos
and that's what i love about editing but
i'm not at a point where i need an
editor so a lot of them do move into a
folder and kind of out of sight out of
mind
for me to go back to later yeah but i
think that you just hit it on the right
timing yeah no i think i i got really
lucky definitely with timing as well
yeah i'm gonna i'm now this is my
podcast i have staged a coup and it is
mine so jack now you have to name your
favorite and least favorite thing about
graham because i've turned this into a
hot seat episode sure okay
so
my favorite thing about graham
i know for a fact that uh
i can count on him and by counting on
him i know that a compass encompasses
like a lot of things so like i can
account um
i can count on him for like
a great opinion on something if he says
he's gonna do something i can count on
him that he'll do it you know i can
count on him like i
he's a great person to rely on because
he he uh he always holds through
so
that's i think that's probably the least
favorite the least favorite thing i have
about graham
uh probably
i mean i gotta say it's probably your
frugality honestly
i don't think i i don't i mean i'm not
your girlfriend so i don't think it's
charming you know but i definitely think
like
it's holding you back so much what would
you do what would you spend money on the
person who got a new macbook computer
yeah and it was a great investment a
really really great investment it speeds
up my editing like tenfold and also uh i
think i edit way better on it because i
use final cut now and i could barely
render final cut i had to use imovie on
my mac so what else so what do you want
what do you want me to spend money on uh
i think you have to forget about these
little like five dollar charges even up
to a thousand dollar charges man i just
like because you're spending okay but
you're spending your mental capacity
deliberating in your head over whether
or not you should pay for something for
example when you're negotiating with
with jeremy about buying his old tesla
you're spending so much time
for like pennies to you i mean you're
you're
trying no he wants 45 i was like 40. at
40 it makes sense no he's willing to do
44 i thought no 43 well i don't want to
say i think with graham because i was
worried initially we first started
dating when he talked about bringing on
one full-time assistant and he wanted
driver and different stuff i was worried
that the more he'd make the more he
would change but i feel like
graham's the same because of the things
like this he's always kind of kept his
touch because he knows what it
some of those frugality things are him
just he's still in touch with what it
means to make every single dollar
i think that those weird frugality
things that maybe
just for us and what we see is like it's
five dollars just get over it
for him it's kept graham graham and
that's why still now i mean obviously
there's ways that both of us have
matured and grown as people over our
relationship but i think it's one thing
that's kept you you mm-hmm and has kept
you so in touch well i was speaking more
so from a business perspective i wasn't
really talking about like from a
personal level because i do think from a
personal level it keeps you grounded
having the amount of money that you have
not willing to spend the extra dollar
for i don't know an extra side or
something like that i think it keeps you
grounded in like like the normal people
out here normally but but like from a
business perspective because you know we
do a lot of business together uh i do
think it could help you uh a lot if you
just what upgraded but tell me what has
been money you have not told me
something that i haven't done i'll say
10 things if you want me to say 10 years
okay okay so one of the things you want
to say something oh no i just was going
to keep count for you oh sure okay so
one of the first things is um
uh the a7s3 camera okay that's on alex
he agreed to it i said yes so get rid of
that's on the way yeah well no i'm just
saying that took two months two months
of convincing fine it's been fine until
then though
no i'm just saying if you would upgrade
it a while i mean do you not want me to
go into that one since it's since it's
salty because yeah that was an issue for
i mean for the current camera's fine
i've never had an issue with the camera
this is this is an upgrade for the
towels and your lights you gotta get it
doesn't make any difference yes it does
yeah any different quality yes
for the viewers i think that look for a
lot of them maybe it won't matter but i
do think if you're going to grow you
need to start investing back into your
channel a little bit man it works i
don't know i like the towels but okay
what's the next one uh
what's up oh just account oh got it okay
sorry
the volvo
uh i think spending a thousand dollars
on the volvo was just i thought that was
the best financial choice i've done that
was one of the best buys this year
okay i disagree with that first of all
because look it's funny for branding you
can negotiate
i use that car
you rarely use that car rarely ever do
you use that car you've probably used it
once in the first four months that we
own the car i've used it he does use it
more than the tesla i will say
but i just don't understand it's like
you have a tesla and you also have a
volvo yeah because you never know when
we need an extra car it's a thousand
dollars sure it's worth five four or
five like it's it's i would be stupid
not to buy that car that car would make
me more money than buying jeremy's tesla
sure okay look okay let me also
i'll just say a few more things as far
as the set for the iced coffee yes uh i
remember i had to call you and double
check and and convince you for a long
time about upgrading some of the things
and and buying some of the things for
the set and that was that was like you
it took a little bit of convincing i
think it was the camera because i said
we had two cannons i think what i think
like what it all comes down to is i
think that you should maybe instill a
little bit more trust in alex and i to
make some of the the more you know the
one thousand to five thousand dollar
decisions because i also i don't even
think it's worth your time to to think
about
uh these little
these little inconveniences for you that
could really improve the business i
think it's not worth your time if we say
graham you need to buy this to make the
business better what do you need right
now
well we still don't have an a7s three
for the main channel you're also
outstanding i'm working on getting that
i still think you should have done the
canon i i think canon has a better color
profile yeah i think they can they tell
me that so
they hooked it up i don't know sony's on
here you guys can make the decision for
yourself we're rocking sony's uh and
then uh canon is hers give me something
to buy
what is it something to buy yeah
we did have to nag you about the wi-fi
the wi-fi yeah
yeah that one sucks
because i would be in the bedroom and
then you'd be uploading something but i
would be on a call with somebody like on
a zoom call and then i would just lose
connection out of a meeting oh because
we didn't get service in the bedroom it
was i didn't get service in my mind like
when somebody was uploading then i would
lose service so when somebody was using
a lot of the bandwidth i would just all
right and that was for a solid like i
want to say the first month that we had
moved in that was bad it was just like a
total issue you couldn't even use the
wi-fi in my room all right so that was
an issue uh and i had to call you to
convince to upgrade the the router uh
another thing was the imax i remember it
had been a long time even though we're
splitting the cost of those examples
what what can i buy now
what do we need now
what do you think alex
because i know you probably also have an
opinion on this
well
the first thing that should be taken
care of is those lights man you you
shouldn't be having towels on your
lights at this level and it does make a
difference i'm telling you
like look at how quality the the
lighting is in here it's it's amazing we
look like graham's main channel like
he's totally overexposed i want to say
half the person half the time okay
that's graham
that's graham that's his brand it's
funny because
oh cause we went to that youtube review
of your channel like maybe get a hair
light but just keep everything the same
yeah even mr beast like you wouldn't
change it but when you what stupid city
wouldn't change anything the only thing
mr b said was i think was an editor
i agree with that i think you should
hire out an editor i do just want to say
though it's like when you when you side
by side someone like ali abdull and
graham and you're just like wow the
production and ali abdullah it's like
who's getting more views
who's getting more views you but you
also have more subscribers and you've
been getting more views for a long
amount of time but i'm just i'm just
saying ali has always said better okay
who's getting more subscribers you are
mr beast and who has higher production
quality yeah that's with totally
different channels you can't compare mr
beast with finance content finance is
too niche yes
is so general you can't you can't do
that
um okay
graham yeah
favorite and least favorite thing about
jack yeah but we're running out of time
so i know that's why i'm trying to let
this go uh how about how about we just
do the uh the favorite thing on jack and
then we'll leave no no i want to know
but we're running no come on i told you
my least favorite thing is
just
make it quick we're running out of time
the more we're talking about this
uh the best thing about jack i like your
ideas and i think you're very proactive
with uh with everything that you do
and uh you're always thinking about the
next thing and how to make something
better so i like i like that you
constantly improve
um
the least i don't know if there's a oh
yeah you have something i don't know if
i have a least uh
he's moving out yeah you're moving out i
don't like that uh at least least least
least
i know what your least favorite what is
it
you've uh you you i mean it's
it's because you guys are different but
uh he prefers to take some time off as
to where you would prefer to work um no
it's not i wouldn't say that's a that's
a least
i mean i'm sure you don't like that but
i do like i i would like to say i do
come back swinging you do like once i
once i take a break it reinvigorates my
uh passion i think the only time that
was bad was when you were also still in
college that was tough but um now it's
like you you take off like two days but
you already are oh you know what half
ahead yeah the only things i could think
of is that there there were a few times
where i was pushing to get something
done like really really really fast and
it's worked out in our favor and i could
tell
uh like for example uh on the second
channel there have been a few videos
there we were like i i give you the
footage at like 6 p.m and it sucks but
i'm like we have to get it out the next
day and you're like
i could tell but you but you did it and
it turned out like really well we've had
some of those really good videos where
they've just
we had to time it
same with the podcast the uh
uh dogecoin guy uh dogepro and uh you
were just about to leave to go and visit
your family i was like no jack we gotta
do it you're like
no we already have another
episode lined up for here i was like
jack we got to do it we got to do it no
it's just to leave right now i'm like
you got it
and that was like one of the most viewed
episodes that we had yeah uh in the
first like two weeks yeah so stuff like
that we did it we did it but i think
there's that element of that you have to
do things immediately and if you don't
strike within that like this
within 24 hours you lose the opportunity
i think those are the opportunities that
get the best i think sometimes you don't
have like a perfect which granted you do
so many other things as well so don't
take this as insulting because there's
probably plenty of these things exactly
like what i'm about to say that i could
be better at i think sometimes
you have a hard time seeing trends
trends trends that are going on like
things or time sensitive trends i think
you know what i think jack sees the
trends but sometimes it's like it's it's
the pain of having to drop your schedule
or change his schedule last minute to
accommodate that that's what i think
it's understandable i know i know that a
lot of times
the only tough thing is usually like
like if it's late and i'm like already
like okay i'm done like i worked or
whatever or if i'm going to visit my
family and i'm already like if i tell
myself i'm leaving at this time you do i
want to leave exactly at that time so
all right macy you want to hear my my
favorite and least favorite thing about
you all right let's do it okay yeah no
i'm gonna oh shoot i'll make it i'll
make it quick all right ready yep my
least favorite thing about you
the dishwasher or the dishwasher the
washer the clothes washer and the dryer
are always occupied yeah it can
sometimes be better remember to there
are clothes in the dryer right now sorry
oh always it's like i always i walk in
with my like my thing i'm like
i'm gonna clean my underwear and then i
open up the thing i'm like okay and then
i walk back in my room and i come back
the next
day and it's the same thing and i'm like
okay and then i walk back and forth it's
like you just text macy yeah well i did
try texting you one time and then and
then you responded exactly like kind of
how i thought you were gonna smile i was
like okay i'm not even gonna bother we
weren't home and i had certain items in
that dryer that i could see
it was a comforter
it was comfy oh i didn't check the dryer
i just checked the washer yeah in the
dryer that i didn't want you pulling out
because i felt very uncomfortable with
you finding those items in there okay
all right well that's my least favorite
thing my favorite thing is uh you take
really good care of me
oh thanks great all right and that's it
guys all right cool with that said thank
you so much for watching we gotta go
until next time thanks so much subscribe
subscribe uh hit the like button hit the
notification bell
get a free stock down below in the
description hungrybox oh hungryball
bankroll coffee bankroll coffee you can
do all of that down below in the
description savannah smiles
everybody thank you so much for watching
smash like button until next time
everyone don't forget to end the video
in the middle of ascent